las multitudes se abarrotan frente a las
puertas de este campus de bangkok
las cadenas finalmente ceden y cientos
de manifestantes entran en el recinto
universitario
debemos recuperar nuestra democracia
nuestra lucha no debe ser en vano todos
hacen el mismo gesto tres dedos
levantados en el aire la señal de la
unión de los opositores a quienes
ostentan el poder tailandés la mayoría
de los manifestantes son estudiantes han
estado marchando casi a diario desde
este verano para exigir más democracia
en el país
debe haber transparencia debemos tener
el derecho de saber lo que pasa en
nuestro país y no solo recibir órdenes
de nuestros líderes
entre las reivindicaciones de este
movimiento prodemocrático el fin del
acoso a los opositores políticos la
disolución del parlamento la dimisión
del primer ministro pero también la
revisión de la constitución de 2017
redactada cuando la junta militar estaba
en el poder parte de este movimiento
también ataca a la monarquía y condena
la interferencia del rey en los asuntos
políticos algo nunca antes visto en este
país donde el crimen de lesa majestad se
castiga con 3 hasta 15 años de cárcel
los activistas prodemocracia
en el domingo a la casa de gobierno para
presentar sus demandas esperan organizar
la mayor manifestación desde el golpe de
estado de 2014